the Kovan 19 crisis created a serious
recession worldwide and put the european
economy on its knees now we need 750
billion euros to rebuild our union a new
EU that is sustainable green socially
inclusive digital and doesn't leave
anyone behind and there are solutions to
find that kind of money without making
most citizens paint Member States
leaders need to take action today
millions of jobs are at risk and the
risk is greater than ever that we lose
sight of the climate emergency the risk
is high that like after the 2008 crisis
billions will be handed to banks while
the cost of the crisis will be paid by
the citizens through austerity measures
we're not going to let that happen
Europe needs more money for its citizens
now more than ever to save jobs to save
is a means to improve our health care
system to insulate houses to invest in
train and bike lanes in cleaner energy
and farming which can create millions of
green jobs by stimulating the flow of
revenues to the EU own resources are
basically money that go into the
European Union budget without adding
further pressure either on people or on
national budgets but rather by pursuing
policies that no member state could
efficiently implement on its own such as
the protection of the environment and
the preservation of a fair and social
Europe the key issue is what do we find
that money
we have proposed several options of the
largest companies in the you contribute
and pay their fair share of taxes right
now multinational companies Harbor in
their game in fiscal heavens don't pay
any tax on the profit they make the
average corporate tax rate in Europe has
fallen by half over the last 40 years
with a solid corporate tax rate agreed
at EU level we could stop the race to
the bottom and generate the resources
necessary to face common European
challenges we have big digital companies
like Google and Amazon which benefit
from loop
but sometimes they pay no taxes at all
in Europe so if an agreement is not
reached at the international level
Europe should take the lead if we tax
big digital companies we will have
enough money to finance entirely the
next generation new if we tax the
digital companies we could supplement
the budget of our Union and make our tax
system fairer we need to reduce the
plaque of tax evasion and tax frauds
that takes money from the citizens but
you also need to finally start taxing
financial transactions big financial
players need to pay their fair share to
society when all of us buy a phone we
pay a v80 of minimum 15% even for basic
necessities like food even the most
vulnerable pay a minimum of five point
five percent why is it that buying
stocks on financial markets is taxed at
0.0% we call on all Member States to
finally create a solid financial
transaction tax it will put a stop to
the high frequency trading bits that
lead to massive gains for the financial
sector while threatening our economic
stability
we asked for a single market levy see it
as a subscription the big companies are
the ones that benefit from us building
the single market and if they use it
they have to pay for it that is only
fair such a levy to be proportionally
modulated according to company's
turnover will generate billions to be
spent on our common priorities we should
use this momentum to make our economy
stronger more social and more
sustainable when in mone Treme the
greens will succeed to contribute to
creating millions of green jobs in all
our countries while preserving a
habitable planet we also need to have
the polluters pay
we need measures like a plastic tax to
draw auction revenues of the EU emission
trading scheme and a carbon border
adjustment mechanism
to avoid an outburst of unemployment and
poverty and to win the climate battle
the Socialists and Democrats have
several concrete solutions on the table
now we need the political will of all
European governments if we want these
proposals to move forward it's now or
never
we're now defining the budget for the
next seven years we cannot miss this
opportunity let's work together we can
make our union socially fairer and
greener we call on the European leaders
to agree on our proposals for Europe
future for a better future